so microbial tracking 2 was an  interesting study and actually that was  the first human-related space biology  study  that was sponsored by the space biology  program and so the study was looking at  as i mentioned taking samples from your  environment so we were swagging  different surfaces  dining table  toilet exercise equipment and so forth  and then we were also taking samples  from the crew so we were taking samples  from their mouth from the nose and from  different skin  areas so like forearms and the navels  and behind the ears and so forth so  obviously  these days  so after collecting samples from  the station or the and then those are  returned to the ground and then  obviously we use health throughput  methods to be able to characterize the  microbiome environment and so here's the  snapshots  looking at the relative abundance so the  top 12  genera